in this capsule we will see
the iteration algorithm by vara then one
saw in a previous capsule the
equations of herself that we
identify a condition
on the values ​​associated with the plan
optimum for a decision process
mark comes to give and we mentioned
which existed two algorithms that are going
exploit this condition there for in
get to find the timmer plan ago
a first a great we see now
left rations by values ​​where one says by
value or English you is the origin
because at each iteration it's the
values ​​of the estimated plan we are going to put to
day in autumn another pace and that
sees in a subsequent capsule that
is the iterations by policy or
rather than rice tea or change the
Plastinated values ​​at each iteration
will rather be in charge of politics
so is it now now let's start
by the val nutrition algorithm we
iteration gets the voice if the algorithm
which is really not really understood in
do so we'll start with
initialize our estimate of the
plan value at 0 for all states
possible s is what we will do is
we go on the ground and we want to repeat
until our estimate of the
value does not change so the
changes in the destination either
negligible and at each iteration this
what we will do is that for each
state s will calculate a new one will
update our estimated value of
planty evil that I'm going to call some
bonuses this is the new value from
of current estimates v of the
value of the optimal plan is what we are going
to make a fact we will just apply
the right hand side of the equations of
bleating so it's like we're taking
the equation of bleating we were doing
an assignment from right to left
in the field like that until that
converge so we recognize here this
part there it's the right part of
amman equations then we compute them
but from our in their life
current and it gives us a new
value
for winter for the optimal plan we
call for bonuses
so after making this assignment
there for all states s I check is
what my previous life value and my
new value of the premiums are very
different for all states when I
calculates the difference in absolute value
right now on all the steps
possible if it is smaller than
certain tolerance that must not but that
I have to specify I stop
and if not I'll use bonuses
like and to my new value v estimated
for my plan and I start again so I
will update my values
calculating a table v premium
I check if bonuses have changed
a lot compared to life if that's the
case it becomes repressed if not I stop and
I manage to converge and so that allowed me
to converge to the virtual value
planty badly under the conditions of
tomorrow
and finally to get what is the
plan team by associating it with what we do
that's what I described previously
that is, my plan is going
match to take the action to who has
the best future reward hope
given my estimate v of the
optima plan value so what that
does it mean that my plan pi2 is this
that I will return with the result
of my to heal that will match a
pitiful is they returning the action
who is the most valuable
so the biggest estimates of the
future reward hope who is so in
is the sum of dvds premium weighted by
if you are at your premium
lure that will be chosen the one who steals
the greatest value of that term there
also the future reward hope to see
an example of running the algorithm
iteration by values ​​will start with
define a mdp a decision process
brand is very simple or even three
states
01 16 2 and our goal is going to be
to reach state s2 and we have them
transitions here that are labeled so
if I'm at zero and I take
action at a general of 0.21 gas quoted at
0 an incoming producer 0.8 is a
on the other hand if I had taken the action to
two managers profit and one to stay at
0-0 to go to soissons or s21
so I'm guaranteed to stay at 0
now is this so I take
the action odh two young people colleter 1
tomorrow to come back as 0 and 1 0 to the park 0
to go elsewhere
if I had taken the action instead
three days a profit of 1.2 get me to
state s2 then finally she is in
two days before a probability of 1 of
recite s2 cij projection to 5
and if I take the place the action to
four kinds a priority one of hazards and
in this case the possible actions to
from scratch it is at a1 and a2 the
possible actions from s1 co2 and
to troyes then possible actions to
from s2c to 5 and to 4 for
represent my goal that is to achieve
is hard I'm going to express it in the form
of a function to reward what I
have to do in a mdp
so in fact I gave recopa
reward 2-0 as0 and s1 but she
positive reward of 1.6 I am to be
ok so clearly he sees an incentive
clear to get to it is to stay
s2 as long as possible
the rewards factor while
the second we will use its 0.5 y
define more clearly here then in the
swimming I'm going to use in rest
of the example to simplify I'm going
noted m the reward of the vice and if
as being small harry then the value
estimated from for the optimal plan that I
am looking for the state and
if I will note it as being v
then first step we initialize the
values ​​that génissiat read all to zero
and then I update my values ​​of
life by calculating the right theme in
the bellemene equation from my
current estimates of 0.2 v1 and v2
so this here fits the theme of
right i have the rewards in zero plus
the factor d second time the maximum
between doing the action has one that fits
therefore to vegetables products of 0.2 remaining
to stay as0 so in this case this
would that correspond to seeing 0.2 times the
value 1 0 plus a priority of 0.8
staying in agen so over 0.8 times the
value of associated with the state is healthy
the other possible action it would be smells
and in this case I dream Promethean of
stay at 0 so I'll just have it here
the heroes and the subject replaces 0 and
ensuring by their present value which 0
I get 100.5 0-0 match that gives me
10 0 if I did it had one now
the reward in v1 and zero plus zero
point 5 times the maximum between the action at
2 which corresponds with 21.2 to get me to
she 0 so the maximum between will aim
so this is once the value of the state
associated with the action at 2 which is zero so
the value of heroes so the center guy
action room at 2 and the action at three that
associates a probability of 1.2 make me
at s2 so the maximum of zero and v2
again I replace on the
some sum gives and finally for
the state s2 the value are you 2
both i'm going to update her as
being the reward an s2 which is 1
so we remember s2 that's my goal I
will give rewards
I associate a reward of 1 l and s
plus 0.5 times the maximum between the action
at 4 which would correspond to a s1 so the
maximum in v1 and the action to five have a
part of the hours to stay as2 so the
maximum v1 and v2 I'm replaced that me
gives new value for b2 which will be
more than zero but Cuba is equal
now at the hospital had to invest
we can change but the value of v2 has
changed now we restore the
new values ​​of v10 v1 v2 so we
mark all that has changed is the
value transition products
stay the same
and I did my calculations what gives me
new values ​​here 0.5 1.5 but if
it stays at zero so now I have some
new values ​​d 00 points its part 11
020 had built 0.5 v2 of the guys at 1.5
I do a third iteration I
replaces right by the news
values ​​2-0 v1 v2 which gives me
new values ​​for heroes of 0.2
for v12 0.75 for v2 of 1.75 and
now suppose we stop after
these three iterations there ie that
suppose my tolerance rate but
indicated that the changes of both
iterations was not big enough for
justify an operation and that I stop
to estimate values ​​now for
get my plan I will use my
values ​​of life 0 v1 educated for
estimate my policy
an optimal policy in this case
then 2 0 that would be the action so the hac
max between the future reward hope to
take the action
men 1 again one who with a share of
0.2 to get me to stay at 0
part 0.8 will take me 0 to dethrone
a care that I'm going this way this is where
my estimate of the future reward
hope if I take the action to 1 then
my estimate of the reward on
species of the action pole at 2 this is the
estimated value bone 0 so the heroes
why because with a quality a
game stays at zero if I take the action
by two so if I do the calculations I
replaces with my estimate 2 0 and
v1 then if i just saw talk about
transition
it turns out that this term here is
greater than 0.2 which is the estimate
of future reward hope if I
take action two so the tarmac
it's the action that maximizes
rewards future hope six years I
can not be the same as the same calculation for
s1 and s2 I take the action that maximizes
the future recompose hope and when
it would give me the action at 3 for the
rate us 1 and 1.5 for the Hebrew state
and so we mac logically what they
found was that as0 of the
production has one that brings me back the most
possible to the right
is it a game to take the action back to
you who once again delight me the most
possible right to s 2 ps2 but
I try to stay as 2 taking
the action of 5
it is actually that if we had
continued to make the hang of iterations
unfortunately we would not have changed the
political ie we would have
converge towards place so it's beautiful
and well the final plan even if we actually
an estimate that is far from
accurate for the value of the optimal plan
so we are first
iteration by value you in
disadvantage we want is that in fact we
at this threshold to be determined on when is this
to stop estimating the value of the plan
optimal and so that could have been that
would have determined when we decided
to stop too much water and that finally
have not yet converged on the
optimal plan so really to have the
guaranteed to find the small male plane
you actually have to key yourself up
convergent
but in practice actually
these posts so when up
convergence through to convergence of
values ​​but in fact it's possible to
find the plan the title well the sale
have accurately estimated the
values ​​associated with the optimum plan so
that's the iteration algorithm by
value or balue and orrit and finally
I will add that if you want to see a
example a little more interesting you
invite to see this address here where
there is a small demonstration of
the iteration algorithm by value
in an example with a little more of
tops then a little more complex